[Musik]
darf ich den antrag der automotive an
den anfang
wie zum beispiel sozialausschuss und
piepsige stimme noch ganz am anfang
schon aufgefallen es ist ein
programmiert ein clip macht sagt hallo
ich bin selbst sehr gut und einmal noch
seriös orte hallo willkommen bei der
tagesschau
die tagesspanne und dank des kraftakts
hübschen retten
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute möchten wir euch erzählen
dass wir einen shop eröffnen
ja und zwar keinen onlineshop gibt es ja
schon seit dem haben sie hinter november
2013 das ist das einzige um was es sich
lohne spaß das ist das einzig warten
will mich jetzt nach anderen daten
fragen die kindergeburtstage alles genau
geburts fünfzehnter november 2013
das klingt wie aus der kanone gestreuten
viel mehr leute sagen heute form ja
häufig verließ einfach so als ob wir
eröffnen einen shop und zwar einen
stationären laden als ein ladengeschäft
über uns so auf deutsch sagen will
in mannheim und ja wir sind ziemlich
aufgeregt denn wir sind gerade noch
mitten in der bauphase und der shop so
was gleich das datum sagen ja also der
shop wird am vierten vierten eröffnen
ursprünglich war märz geplant
arbeitsmarkt kommen wir machen uns nicht
selber den stress und dem druck wer
öffnen am vierten vierten das ist ein
samstag
da denke ich auch dass dann eben auch
viele von euch kommen können darauf zu
räume ja gemerkt aber sonntags aufräumen
und
der q6 q7 in mannheim sein
ja es ist mitten in der stadt neues
einkaufszentrum richtig cool das ist ein
bisschen mehr als überraschend ihren ja
ich denke schon dass wahrscheinlich und
ist ja auch das einkaufszentrum über
weil es da drin also das prinzip dieses
einkaufszentrum war einfach dinge im
einkaufszentrum zu haben wie es die
stadt nicht
ja also nicht doppelt gemoppelt dem ist
also nicht dass es ein neues gibt h m in
der innenstadt nicht das rad noch mal
ein ja und es gibt halt marken und läden
die die jetzt nicht überall vertreten
sind das ist wirklich coole besondere
dinge auch und ich finde es echt super
schön und vielleicht noch ganz kurz denn
das habe ich letzte woche erst gelernt
wieso heißt dieses einkaufszentrum q 6 q
denn man habe ich schon der
quadratestadt das wusste ich so dieses
schachbrett stadt mannheim ist so und q
6 q 7 weil eben das eine gebäude auf q 6
steht das andere auf q7 oder hat es so
eine brücke
das ist überall so in wien mit dem
bezirk bezirk 12 bzw
ok dann mal kurz ein schachbrett
aufgeklärt und wir sind dann im gebäude
q6 oben im ersten ok und vielleicht noch
ganz kurz warum wir etwas also brauch
ich zumindest warum ich zumindest
aufgeregt bin denn wir sind gerade noch
mitten in der bauphase das heißt alex
und juni und der wolke
die sind damit dabei und ich hatte auch
ich auch ich habe auch noch meine ganzen
ideen und wir haben als er ist ein
richtiger was machen so ganz genau
zumindest haben wir doch noch kein
festes aber wir haben unser team ist
avatar hatte schon depressiv
arbeitsstelle pressekontakt genau uns ja
dass man jetzt im kino immer wenn ich
irgendwas mache meine presse
kontrolliert die nach ist autowaschen
macht diepresse.com von hier und die
auch zu kann man doch noch baby dry wo
genau und pressekonferenz eine coole
geschichte und viele bezahlt haben wir
schon viele sagen gehabt also intern
viele
angeschrieben wir haben gesagt ist es
nicht ein rückschritt
ja genau weil führung denkt sollen weil
viele denken
wer es ist nur fortschritt wenn man in
die digitale welt eintaucht also wenn
man digitalisierung macht so jetzt sind
wir ein digitales unternehmen was ja
digital angefangen hat und wir machen
einen stationären laden und dann haben
hat uns wirklich jeder gefragt ist das
nicht ein rückschritt weil wir nicht
verrückt weil er momentan zu machen um
ihr macht einen auf wir denken so dass
im regal ja im prinzip kannst du dazu
muss man vielleicht so eine kleine
vorgeschichte wieso machen wir das
überhaupt wir hatten schon vor einigen
jahren die anfrage auch aus großen
städten also jetzt nicht dass man eine
kleine stadt wäre aber aus richtig groß
steh auf berlin münchen und hamburg
da gab es ein kaufhaus das wollte es um
macht genau das problem aber als wir
haben die zeit nicht gehabt heute auch
nicht ist noch nicht bereit dafür aber
auch dem auge zeigt aber man kann ich
weit bis 25 30 minuten rathäuser für uns
heimspielen weil mannheim ist im prinzip
wissen in waghäusel wir wurden genau
zwischen mannheim heidelberg und
karlsruhe und mannheim
ich halte für uns so die nächste
großstadt für uns dort menschen ist
schon eine große stadt und da kann man
schnell was sagen und wenn es jetzt in
hamburg gewesen wäre dann wäre mir
sicher nicht dort gewesen also möglich
wenn irgendwas richtig zurück oder wenn
man gerade nicht und das ist was daheim
sondern ist nur schönheit genau deswegen
bei der heimreise sind
ja ja darf man und warum wir das jetzt
machen also wenn man das ist echt auch
lange überlegt natürlich mal macht der
pro und contra und wir sind ja auch im
jahr auf mehreren messen letztes jahr
war das erste mal seit 2005 10 dass wir
auf keiner messe waren und ich hab echt
vermisst man jetzt also unsere zuschauer
haben es auch vermisst sie ist an dem ab
was seid ihr wieder da wir wollen euch
doch live erleben und wir haben uns
einfach gedacht hier werden mittlerweile
einfach so eine große community so viele
zuschauer die uns auch immer treffen
wollen warum machen wir nicht einfach
einen stationären shops in denen wir
eben auch also zu dem wir öfter gehen
können als jetzt auf eine messe denn
messe bedeutet für uns immer das
komplette team einpacken zwei wochen
lang nur für die messe vorbereiten und
der shop wenn der alma steht dann zimmer
da echt auch mal schnell spontan wenn es
die zeit zulässt und vor allem haben wir
mittlerweile einfach kann man es sagen
einfach auch so tolle produkte die man
einfach anfassen muss gusseisen töpfe wo
man einfach sich so denkt hey das musste
mal in der hand gehabt haben einfach mal
anfassen um zu wissen hätte es hat echt
eine tolle top qualität
ja und wir wollen einfach mal ihr wissen
wir sind menschen die wir lieben
herausforderungen wir machen momentan
irgendwie eine herausforderung nach der
anderen
wir wissen dass gerade zum beispiel und
katalog gemacht ja und jeder hat gesagt
warum machen die ausstellung im katalog
ich muss zugeben ich war auch einer
davon
murat also das war wirklich musste gegen
den undertaker seiner drucke der lampe
drucker drucktechnologie und ich weiß
einem coolen look zu machen und jeder
gesagt warum macht ist noch jemand das
macht doch keiner hat aber wahnsinnig
eingeschlagen muss ich ehrlich sagen ich
sag was das für dieses jahr wieder gut
machen werden dass sogar zuschauer
gesagt haben wo kann ich dieses buch
bekommen und ich denke oft nach meiner
meinung warum macht ihr etwas zwischen
auch damals positions- gesagt haben wenn
ihr noch größer werden wollten machen
und dann geht die große navi müssen nach
berlin
und wir haben kinder bleibt zu hause und
wiesen da getrieben und beim katalog auf
bilder
warum macht ihr das gesagt keiner macht
es also machen wir es jetzt mal ob
jemand zu hoffen das ist auch im
stationären keine machtspiele mal zu ja
und wir sagen okay wir machen machen wir
einen drauf dabei müsst ihr euch das so
verstehen das war jetzt nicht so eine
spontane nach fraktion gesagt hey wir
machen das jetzt einfach für uns
bedeutet ist natürlich auch viel
vorbereitung eine herausforderung
natürlich auch risiken natürlich sie
liegen oft abends im bett denken so war
das letzte richtige entscheidung wobei
jetzt bin ich echt an so einem punkt wo
ich mich richtig mega drauf freuen und
ich denke das war doch das machen wir
und wir machen da was cool ist raus
vielleicht ganz kurz was mich dort
erwartet also wir machen unseren job auf
da gibt es natürlich alle unsere sachen
kitchenaid kommt mit rein kenwood kommt
mit demonstrationen was sagen man fragt
immer passen euro konzept anders als bei
an dass wir kein konzept
wir machen einfach aus dem fach gefühl
genau und aber school war einfach es ist
mit kitchenette flagship store geben mit
farben dieses die es nirgendwo anders
geben wird es wird ein kenwood flagship
store gibt mit dingen die es nicht um an
das geben wird also nur in mannheim und
natürlich auch unsere dinge die es auch
nur in mannheim geht also das konzept
einfach dass man dinge den menschen
bietet die ist nicht überall wo sich das
wichtige und was das ganz besondere am
shop sein wird dass viele uns einen als
welche saßen unser darüber gesprochen
haben und haben also in die küche gucken
ich habe gesagt ja wir müssen einfach
meine küche die hier hinter mir steht
einfach in mannheim auch aufbauen denn
die also immer wenn ich fragen auf
instagram youtube oder facebook
beantwortet sind es fast 50 prozent
fragen zur küche sowie wie organisiert
die schubladen was hast du den schränken
wie lassen sich die fronten abwischen
wie ist die arbeitsplatte und dann haben
wir gedacht haben nehmen einfach die
küche mit bauen die auch auf und im
prinzip seht ihr dann dort genauso aus
wie hier ein bisschen kleiner vielleicht
natürlich habe ich auch meine bosch
küchengeräte dort in meiner küche
genauso wie zu hause und wenn ihr dazu
fragen habt könnt ihr sie gerne stellen
vor ort oder eben auch vor ort beraten
lassen und dann können wir dort einfach
auch live events machen ihr könnt ihr
könnt die küche anschauen ihr könnt
darin stehen entlang auf machen diese
organisiert ihr könnt euch da hinstellen
wo ich immer stehen könnten foto machen
also ich glaub das macht den job dort
einfach zu unserem zweiten zuhause genau
also auch nicht immer so sein den
teppich neben war mir diese teppiche war
susann er das heißt denkt dann
vielleicht manche hinter trägt und wir
werden auch trainiert stellen wir uns
einem dienstag mal lust haben dann
nehmen wir auch zusammen nach mannheim
und drehen einfach ein video das zeigt
wie einkaufen und ich finde ich kann mir
so lustig vorsteuer jetzt machst dann
kunis koch video und jetzt kommen die
leute rein und ich wollen vielleicht nur
shoppen oder willst du mir nicht vor die
kamera und sagt komm jetzt probiert es
mal live vor allen zuschauern die
klassen richtig coole interaktion und
was auch cool ist das vielleicht
irgendwelche prominenten menschen kommen
könnten andere youtuber auch hier zb
einen
samstag machen hier live events mit
strombach oder mit coupons oder mit
wiederholen
dieter bohlen kommt am samstag 16 zu uns
zum beispiel nach nach mannheim um 6 q 7
und machten kochen live auf youtube und
so eine interaktion auch wieder
einzubringen dass die menschen die dort
drin sind auch jeder überrascht sind
kann ich dann den recall
ja du kommst in rico
[Musik]
das werden wir alle das kaufhaus
verlassen und einfach so die geschichte
wo die menschen in interaktion drei
nimmst und natürlich auch mit der
grüningen ich bin ich mal spontan
mittags um 16 uhr zeit haben sich zum
könig klinikum
lasst uns mal ein bisschen shop gehen
und mit den leuten reden ist ein fan
shop und regnet in zukunft muss ich dich
auch dann gar nicht mehr einkaufen
schicken
dann sagen sie einfach schatz in
mannheim die brauchen dich ja aber
garantiert nicht dass wir denken dass
wir jeden tag dass sie gerne auf das war
nicht das ist doch keine arbeit mehr
wir müssen auch unsere alltäglichen
videos weitermachen also wir gar nicht
mehr spontan da sein und auch angebot
auch angekündigt dass man gerne sagen am
wer nur jetzt in mannheim und ja ihr
programm konform und dann machen wir
immer spaß und ist einkaufen so dass ich
ein erlebnis sein er ist ganz ganz klar
dinge werden euch gezeigt und alle
fragen stellen die ihr so immer auf dem
herzen habt also jetzt nicht im bezug
auf morath und mich hat das so aber so
fragen mit der hefe funktioniert nicht
oder was mache ich wenn man backpulver
so sachen könnte dort dann vor ort oder
ihr wisst was ich meine oder weiß was
ich meine ja und der star der seht ihr
dann aus wie bei uns zu hause also die
küche ist da der esstisch der teppich
das heißt wenn ihr wirklich mal in diese
in unsere welt einfach und wolltest
ellis welt sehen wollt dann könnt ihr
uns einfach dort in mannheim besuchen da
können wir alles vor ort anschauen
ich meine es gibt ja auch viele die hier
gerne mal vorbei fahren aber er war ja
bei dir wohnen hier wir arbeiten hier
das bist du das können wir nicht machen
aber in mannheim da könnt ihr jederzeit
hin da könnt ihr euch alles anschauen
gibt es auch mal im café genau da gibt
es menschen die zeit haben genau ich
hoffe sogar dass wir immer kuchen da
haben wir uns gesprächen und backen
lernten auch jetzt noch nicht
versprochen also ja ich irgendwann
vielleicht machen wir auch mal was mit
kochen backen und wir müssen uns selber
noch überlegen ich meine wir sagen wir
haben kein konzept bei uns ist immer
alles so bauchgefühl
was wir jetzt gerade worauf sie gerade
lust haben versuchen wir umzusetzen und
glaub das macht uns ja auch aus ja ich
habe es gar ein bisschen mit ihm ja und
wenn ihr richtig coole geschichte vor
allem alle sind da genießt da alex sah
ich bin dankbar dass nicht immer aber
immer öfter ohne dann natürlich neue
teammitglieder haben die marktpartner
der müssen denn wir werden neue
teammitglieder haben die suchen uns
gerade aus erster hand verlesen
bitte glaubt nix über sind kameras
natürlich auch nicht schlecht schaut
doch keiner wollte sagt in china
übrigens wenn ihr von weiter weg kommt
das habe ich mich dann auch schon
gefragt und dachte mir so was sagte man
menschen die vielleicht noch weiter weg
kommen und die da auch hinkommen also
ich muss dazu sagen unsere region hier
die metropolregionen mannheim
rhein-neckar und karlsruhe heidelberg
ist wirklich eine richtig schöne region
also wir in waghäusel
ich will jetzt nicht so viel werbung
machen damit zwar kosten nicht zu voll
wird aber unsere region er ist wirklich
schön also wir haben alle tollen städte
um uns herum heidelberg ist so schön
mannheim ist superschön man kann ganz
toll essen gehen es gibt viel zu erleben
jetzt momentan steht zum beispiel das
palazzo in mannheim
dann könnte in heidelberg in die
altstadt in mannheim herumschlendern ich
glaube da müsste man echt mal wie so
eine art weißt du sowas gibt es vor ort
ich möchte nicht als mama fragt mich
doch mal was kann ich noch mit den
kindern machen außer jetzt in so einen
indoor spielplatz zu gehen gibt ganz
tolle spielplätze bei uns die alle
hauptspiel etwas in mir den mund
die super mega grassiert für
sehenswürdigkeiten bei uns in der region
haben könnte es dann verbinden und sagte
er aus bereits drei stunden und der
seite gleich eine stunde bei uns im
flagship store und dann habt ihr den
amerikanischen erleuchteten keks
gegangen ist weil wir da raus und dann
können wir euch um wie coole restaurants
empfehlen oder sehenswürdigkeiten auch
dinge die vielleicht kostenlos im ersten
paar gespräche kostenlos sondern im park
der eintritt zur kosten seien aber wenig
eintritt
grasen nein stuttgart er hat voll viel
wasser spielplätze
da hat's pflanzen da hat schmetterlinge
haus die tiere wohl geld hallo bei
straße dann trocknet das ist folger
schön gepflegte park da gibt's pinguin
ich ja dann gibt kriterium
ok ich glaube es war schon jahrelang
hier ich muss in mannheim wasserturm ich
auf und schön da gehe ich auch vor ja
nicht sehen dass der klimawandel in
mannheim anders ist und das sitzt
inzwischen pinguin im luisenpark sehr
sehr interessant ich war als kind immer
in diesen tagen lernen trotzdem ich
werde euch vermissen
ich werde euch ein paar
sehenswürdigkeiten finden die kostenlos
sind zwei jahren die die burg in hamburg
kostet auch geld
er schafft alles was halt gepflegt
werden kosten die burg ist doch klar
sie schlägt sein im 15 jahrhundert ja
und aber das muss halt hier schon längst
bezahlt mein gott zu tun ist so willst
du warst du kinder globus gehen nach
waghäusel ja also das ist das vielleicht
noch zur eröffnung die findet am 4
vierten start
nähere infos aber noch nicht denn wir
haben die hoffnung noch nicht geplant
aber ihr könnt ja mal ich bin ich frage
mich dann immer so was erwarten menschen
bei der eröffnung
ich weiß auch nicht was auch cool ist
ich war schon mal hier ist voll
was auch cool ist wir bauen den shop
selber ja also selber klar dass sie
hilft uns von trust & partners der hat
im prinzip alles gezeichnet was wir so
an ideen hatten und wir haben ideen
gemeinsam einfach entwickelt und wir
sollten unsere anschrift tragen das hat
unsere produkte steht uns halt aus als
bei sind alles natürliche dinge ist
heißt nun alles natürlich mit holz die
die beleuchtung gesagt unser shop das
soll so sein trabant techniken jedoch
außen der bereich es wird alles alles so
wie es bei uns zu hause ist wird auch
der shop aussieht und dass kein bett zum
schlafen hat und das coole
er hat
es ist ja schon gesagt und wir haben
ungefähr voll im jahr einfach mal
versucht einen eigenen shop aufzubauen
ist auch eine garantie dass haben doch
die bilder zeigt das rad der schock der
den hof belegt hat hier noch und zwar
hat er mit shop wirklich drei monaten
hoch gelegt weil wir haben einfach man
hatte nicht einfach so und sagte ich zu
mir egal reinstellen macht ihren stimmt
und vor einem jahr haben wir schon mal
so ein konzept gemacht wie gewohnt seine
shop aussehen und haben die ganzen
regale geschweißt ich habe geschrien hat
geschwitzt das sind zwei verschiedene
dinge mit kinderecke übrigens denn ich
hab sagt ganz ehrlich wenn ich als mama
einkaufen gehen oder ins restaurant
essen geht finde ich es immer einfach
mega entspannt wenn die kinder
beschäftigt sind
das heißt wenn wir schon mal essen gehen
dann nehmen wir das selber was mit zum
spielen oder wir gehen einfach nur in
restaurants wo es eben so eine spielecke
hat und das finde ich mega cool das
heißt wir machen auch eine kleine
spielecke jetzt aber überlegt ob man
dies auch abschließbar sollen die kinder
ranmachen übrigen schlüsselt erlaubt
nämlich wunderkindes abschläge auf dem
nicht das stimmt gar nicht
die spielecke also ich hab momentan noch
vor die spielecke selber zu bauen
denn wir würden gerne dass der spieler
an der wand machen und dann hab ich mir
schon was cooles überlegt es war dann
noch umsetzen ich hoffe nur die zeit
reicht also ich hoffe dass ich das noch
umsetzen los meint ja kriegen wir hin
was auch cool ist dann ist gegenüber für
uns im shop ist eine sportsbar finde ich
interessant zu wissen weil dann kann man
die männer gerade über schicken sagen
ich gehe also gegenüber der sport war es
okay da können dahinter die männer
können hin die frauen können dann bei
uns an nämlich dabei und stunden genau
da hatte ich das nicht doch das ist wie
es ist
neben uns ein schock ist in bayern
münchen fan shop lewis ist familie und
nachbarn kann sie nicht aussuchen
du kannst ihn dir mal macht ans packen
ich mag den mal schön muffins dort hund
wird nicht glaub das wird so nicht
kommen
ich freue mich auf diesen bayern münchen
fan shop wenn die können ja nichts dafür
dass ein paar sachen
ein fall ich werde jetzt natürlich wird
er jeden tag ärgern und ok ich bin
gespannt was ich für nichts garantieren
ja jedenfalls habe ich schon angefangen
ich mein job ist wirklich ein toller
kameramann aber ich habe schon
angefangen mit meinem handy immer wenn
ich da bin einfach so eine rundum
drehung zu machen ich mache am ende mein
eigenes noch mein eigenes video
aber wie gesagt ansonsten was ist auch
von anderen unterscheiden die meisten
songs die heute gemacht werden oftmals
wird gemacht werden pop-ups gemacht mehr
stimmt und pop-ups ronson meisten stores
mit also neue englisch ich mag das
selber nicht aber die haben einfach den
namen keine ahnung bild da selber nicht
pop up stores sind dort die man monat
auf haben zwei monaten eine woche nur
genau und dann machen wir wieder zu und
wandern dann einfach das waren früher
die nomaden holz ist die pop up stores
und die wanderbühne ja genau die
wandelnde und es und das ist ein
flagship store und flagship store heißt
einfach flagship flaggschiff das heißt
der allererste habe mich richtig
übersetzt flagship wer der erste ist und
ich sage auch jetzt gleich etwas dazu
was was ich jetzt sage bitte tut mich in
einem monat an einem jahren nicht an
dieser aussage
was macht er jetzt so und zwar werde das
einzige sein das ist schon ganz ehrlich
ich muss euch ganz ganz ehrlich sagen
ich noch keine zeit jetzt waren alle
spaß machen wirklich aber du musst immer
spaß machen da wenn nein ich in der
zukunft dieses video zu mach's nicht ich
mache es nicht wirklich reden wir haben
jedes traders
wenn du das video siehst in zwei jahren
macht nicht wirklich weil du hast die
zeit dazu habe ich wirklich nicht gut
aussieht
was meinst du wie demokrat in zukunft
das waren glauben gleich hinter zukunft
etwas leichter ist liegt es daran dass
dann wieder abend ins fitnessstudio geht
ja diesmal stunden ja unsere anlagen ich
finde mich ob steak automaten und ich
glaube ich bin ich sehr gut aus in
zukunft lieber wo radstadt zukünftigen
wir machen es macht keinen sinn immer so
lustig toll ausland wo es sauber einer
reihe jetzt zweimal einfach mal hin
falls beweisen wenn man hier rumsitzen
wird da auch nicht schneller fertig also
auch einmal zehn guck mal wie weit die
jungs sind was zu bringen dann freuen
wir uns auf die eröffnung noch was ja
ich hab's vergessen
liebes zukünftige ich verließ die
tabletten nicht gleich
[Musik]
volkwein mannheim kennt noch nicht so
oft aber wir sehen dass wir sind q 6 q 7
und zwar links von uns ist espoo 63 sein
kursiven risiko sie und hier ist krieg
mettmann am kleinen schild genau wie
gesagt quadraten stadt und oder
schachbrett statt und wir sind mit
niemand bei der festmesse nennt sich so
weil die tiere fressen ganzen tag schon
erwähnt habe ich schon im jahr also hier
ist q 6 q 7 und unserem shop findet ihr
im kost exponate geben jetzt einfach mal
zusammen rein oder hängt guck mal wenn
ihr hier konkret dann seid ihr richtig
dagegen zu wenig denn max doch seht und
dann die rolltreppe einfach hoch laufen
natürlich diesen coup laufen weil die
verformung ja meine ich doch
so jetzt sind wir eigentlich kurz vorm
job hier ist unser shop und es ist etwas
unglaubliches passiert ich habe euch ja
gesagt
verwandte und nachbarn kann man sich
nicht aussuchen und bei aber ich weiß
nicht warum mir das passiert es gibt
nicht viele bayern münchen fan shops in
deutschland und jetzt ist einer direkt
neben mir
es ist eine unglaubliche geschichte und
ich durfte hier den inhaber schon
kennenlernen den store manager und
trainer daniel begrüßen ich bin ein
richtiger dann weiß ich bin dortmund-fan
tja und was meine zuschauer immer schon
wissen wollten ist ein store manager
eines bayern münchen fan stores selber
bayern münchen fans einmal ganz ehrlich
natürlich der wird man glaubt dass man
gebraucht weil dabei ist sagte gerade
gemerkt er wird der vielzahl dass dieses
gilt dass er das jetzt gesagt hat du
dich für hat weiß ich bin doch und fans
so das ist echt gesagt hast gesagt
daniel hopp sieben brüder die stimme
laden hier aber eine krasse geschichte
dann passiert folgendes wir werden
wahrscheinlich freunde werden wir zwei
so aber man muss es ja nicht übertreiben
und jetzt habe ich einen deal für dich
okay ich habe mir das überlegt daniel
mandl folgendes wenn dortmund dieses
jahr meister wird okay ja was passieren
wird dann möchte ich wirklich einst von
ihr haben wenn es wirklich ein bild für
götter du bist der typ der in bayern
münchen fenster arbeiten im doppel
ok gegenleistung ist wenn du gewinnst
und bayern münchen meister wird dann
verwirrt was wenn sie einfach nur geld
haben
danach dann werde ich in zukunft wenn
ich im storting in bayern münchen breno
krank spiels neujahr bayern münchen
später war dann natürlich auch sie sie
schnell auf wie kannst du kurz weg gehen
welt ab heute bin ich bayern münchen
das ist jetzt ein spieler den ich kenne
und dänemark und lewandowski ist das
volk hören
das ist die luft im einkauf sind so
daniel auf die gute nachbarschaft bayern
münchen
ihr habt sogar ein toaster was stimmt
mit euch nicht die kriegt den hals nicht
wurde das gibt mir reden auch noch super
bayern jetzt alle spaß
sie haben ein toaster der sprit
superbayern wie das super feiern super
bayern geschafft ganz weil bayern gehen
natürlich niemals die champions nicht
gewinnen wird haben sie sich noch
schlüsselanhänger gemacht dass sie
wenigstens im programm haben aber jetzt
fertig zu machen das ist mein job
halbzeit die haben eierbecher daniel hey
daniel links doch von den toten das
gibt's doch nicht
ein becher von bayern münchen bis ich
nicht normal also jetzt gehen wir über
und ich zeig mal daniel wir sind ja auch
eine gute nacht
hinter uns seht ihr denn shop jetzt
gerade auch zu denn wir bauen ja noch 14
meter und höher die fensterfläche
laufmeter wird komplett aufgemacht wird
riesengroß gegenüber ist komme also
schon mal das qs was oliver eigentlich
habe ich mir den standort nur ausgesucht
hatte ich sehr gut finde weil ansonsten
habe ich halt nehmen dann würde ich kein
shoppen zu gehen
aber ehrlich aber der muskel ist
ungelogen ich bin kein großer einkäufern
aber wenn ich einkaufen gehe ich zum
markt und technologie sport und ich bin
natürlich ganz klar in den bayern schon
aber schatzkanzler ich auch gute
nachbarschaft da muss man doch irgendwie
so als einweihung montag kanal und
wasser das den meeren die bombe
naja wir backen dann war es und dann
kriege ich backe mit sicherheit nichts
wie beim ok kommt jetzt noch mal rein
und einmal den schock vorgenommen
ein kommando dreimal glück
danke also erst mal mein gott ich darf
ja tut mir leid du bekommst
denn auf diese dinge die mir 14 12 ich
weiß nichts da vernehmlich erwarten dass
aber irgendwo muss doch haben sie
geschäftsleute
[Gelächter]
wir sind jetzt bei uns im shop und zwar
im q 6 q 7
sally flagship-store es wird gehämmert
vom alex nicht vom juni und jetzt zeigen
wir euch mal was dabei gedacht haben was
ich selber gedacht hat was ich mir
gedacht habe was da alles ist gesagt hat
was du nicht gedacht so kommt ich nicht
mehr zu als ich hier auf der seite dass
es direkt wenn man dann reinkommt da
kommt eine lebensgroße kitchenaid rein
also wirklich eine riesengroße drei
meter große kitchenaid und hier wird
dann so unsere kitchenaid ecke seien
hier in der mitte bis in unsere eigenen
produkte also focus eisen und sagt er
die bank welche back rahmen und so
weiter vorne hier an der ecke kommt die
kassen aber da muss man ganz kurz kommen
damit die farbe ist die schon so oft
musste ich hab die schulen schon fertig
so giftgrün
richtig farbig kann es sein dass du dir
auch zum probieren
ich war aber gestrichen sowie daheim so
dass jungs hatte dunkle grün hat das ist
falsch weiß warum das war eigentlich die
farbe für mamas küche ursprünglich und
das was das grün was wären wir mit gras
können aber dunkle halle zwischen grafen
tschuldigung entschuldigung die dorf
komme sei haben wir gehen weiter und die
boxen den jetzt gerade so verteilt im
raum stehen das sind einem screens drin
und zwar wird hier von die fensterfront
die seht ihr jetzt noch wird komplett
verdeckt und dann kommt da ein riesen
led panel hin und da können wir dann
videos abspielen videos und bilder und
das sieht man dann aus und von der
freßgass' also wenn man dann wirklich
nach oben schaut dann sieht man bei uns
kein schaufenster sondern eben einen
bildschirm und stahl lassen wird dann
eben alles laufen worauf er gerade lust
haben ja hier in der ecke
da kommt dann unser regal hin diese
regalwand die wir eben auch zu hause
haben also die holzwand wo die
kühlschränke drin sind
und genau hier in der mitte da und hat
der oder da wo das podest ist da ist man
eben die küche und die bauen wir dann so
auf wie zu hause und was fehlt noch
da links kommen tägliche hin und da
vorne noch die kinderecke und es ist
eigentlich so grob
das wird unser shop momentan pendelt
kann man sich noch nicht so ganz
vorstellen aber ich kann nicht mal
vielleicht ein club- eigentümer mit als
ich es dir die küchen pläne und im
prinzip die küche wirklich aus wie zu
hause
die küchenplanung ging auch superschnell
dieses mal denn wir mussten praktisch
nur unsere alten küchen plan nehmen und
praktisch den neuen gegebenheiten
anpassen
also haben wir dieses podest gebaut da
können da alex so können wir alle
leitungen den ganzen strom wasser
abwasser und so weiter darunter
verstecken und die küche ist eben dann
auch ein bisschen erhöht so dass es auch
wenn eben mehr menschen hier drin sind
trotzdem alle sichtbar ist und die bauen
wir jetzt hier hin zu verschwinden
sondern auch die led leinwand dahinter
wo man sie praktisch kein fenster mehr
und dann sieht halt echt aus wird bei
uns zu hause und die küche kommt anfang
märz da wenn ich jetzt auch noch
gespannt drauf also jetzt muss es noch
mal so richtig richtig abgehen ich
kümmere mich jetzt noch um die
kinderecke versuch da noch ein paar
ideen und noch immer zeichnungen und
dann zeige ich euch einfach demnächst
mal wieder wie es weiter geht also
schreibt einfach in die kommentare gerne
was euch interessiert vielleicht auch
was sie erwartet was ihr cool findet ob
er auch im vierten viertel kommt und
dann freuen wir uns schon riesig auf die
eröffnung geplant
[Musik]